[Música]
na minha infância eu tinha dois grandes
problemas
o primeiro era o meu nome eu não estava
nada de estar sempre a repetir o meu
nome e as pessoas eram assim como é que
chama de o novato e aos não que eu nawa
bueno tinha constantemente estar a
repetir como é que se pronunciava como
escrevia era um stress uma frustração
para uma criança o meu segundo problema
era o meu cabelo
eu não estava no meu cabelo eu não
estava no aspecto frisado não estava no
papel de ser rebelde ser crespo
eu falei eu considerava muito muito
fácil e eu cheguei a um ponto em que o
dia extremamente meu cabelo e eu
desejava fortemente ter um cabelo liso
naturalmente turismo é igual ao da minha
mãe e eu não podia fazer coisas simples
como por exemplo usar o meu cabelo solto
na escola
eu estava muito imenso era o meu sonho
poder fazer isto envia vai meu cabelo
solto sempre há ocupações mas eu não
tinha e caso roriz cas
nos domingos quer o link a minha mãe
cuidava do meu cabelo eu ia chorar ao
roriz era só ver uma escova que já
contava está e eu comecei a notar que
outras campanhas também da minha idade a
minha volta na escola na rua onde eu
vivia só as unidades também passavam por
isto e era impressionante meninas
crianças com uma luta interior já desde
cedo a luta não aceitar aquilo que era
naturalmente delas e não perceber que
não via nada de errado em que nunca viu
assim e não vê nada de errado em seus
diferentes naquela altura era impossível
os adultos tentaram explicar que não
havia nada de errado com nosso
mel porque porque os adultos seguiram um
padrão estético de frente um padrão
estético que nós não percebíamos mas nós
desejávamos porque víamos os alunos a
usarem a seguir a maioria das mulheres
lutas nós tínhamos na nossa volta
eram mulheres que realizava um cabelo
eram mulheres que não aceitava se
inscreveu os créditos e sua luta
aproximar se uma criança e só olha tu
não tens que ficar triste que eu quero é
uma coisa normal aceitas é bonito é uma
criança e eu logo dizendo então por que
não usa o cabelo assim por que não no
flat é que eu conquistasse a tentar
ensinar e no momento crianças são
extremamente inteligentes
vocês também que em cabo verde
existem escolas que o proíbe de entrar
em por terem um cabelo crespo e solto
sim isso aconteceu na escola miraflores
na cidade da praia santiago cabo verde
proíbe meninas de entrarem num país
africano onde as pessoas são negras têm
traços de pessoas negras três pessoas
sociais traz o se as pessoas negras têm
campeão pessoas negras num cabelo crespo
que deveria ser normal entre nós mas não
há opção relativamente ao nosso cabelo
são africanos
o primeiro em africanos por serem
africanos herói não é quando eu ando na
rua as pessoas olham pra mim assim como
o melhor para elas um processo normal
toda a gente passa por isso e quando as
pessoas olham pra mim tanto naturalidade
da eu consigo identificar três tipos de
olhares
o primeio do curiosidade o segundo de
estranheza e o terceiro que é mais forte
e eu consigo identificar
é o olhar racista as suas olham para mim
e esse olhar vão diretamente para o meu
cabelo e quando essas pessoas olham
a mim eu sei que eu gosto de olhar para
um é te foi abduzido há 400 anos e foi
entregue hoje ao mundo pois quero te
esqueças que saem por isso qualquer
coisa do meu deus que está a fazer aqui
na rua amílcar cabral disse que existem
duas principais fontes para nós nos
inspirarmos para nós ganharmos força
relativamente à opção e tudo mais
essas duas condição a cultura ea
identidade
sim isto é identidade não é só um cabelo
e vocês devem estar pronta a gente dar
porque identidade porque escrever um
destino das outras pessoas em outros
pontos de entrada porque o meu cabelo é
infelizmente um dos principais alvos
diretos do racismo identidade porque o
meu cabelo foi por muito tempo e é
considerado infelizmente algumas pessoas
até hoje o cabelo que era triste que uma
pessoa suja de uma pessoa apropriada uma
pessoa não muito apresentável é
associado a uma característica da
escrava que era suja só servia para ser
escravizada e para ser abusada dentro
desta questão cabelos receitação tentar
resistir a tudo para dar padrão estético
europeu que nos é implementado logo na
nossa infância
nós encontramos meninas e mulheres
pessoas negras que tem mudado esta
realidade das pessoas olharem para nós
com aquele olhar racista e das meninas
como eu pensar é que exista algo de
errado com meu cabelo
várias mulheres negras e não só em
plataformas online e também em outras
plataformas estão a influenciar meninas
desde cedo aceitarem os seus cabelos
olharem posso falar e pensar em passar
não existe nada de errado comigo
sou uma pessoa normal não tem que ser
igual a todas as pessoas não existe nada
de mal na diferença eu sou assim
essas pessoas também trabalham muito
conexão não só das pessoas aceitaram
seus cabelos mexe também com a
autoestima autoconfiança dessas meninas
que mais tarde serão mulheres
o futuro de qualquer sítio num país da
nossa cidade
no sítio a que pertencemos essas meninas
começaram a olhar para os seus cabelos
com algo que é a força uma fonte de
força para conseguir resistir
se eu não te ver o que estão a atacar eu
vou usar um contra
eu vou ter amor é eu eu vou aceitá lo eu
vou fazer com que as pessoas acreditem
que não
não há nada de errado eu não é sushi e
long é e apropriado eu faz parte da
minha identidade está tudo bem eu ser
assim
dentro deste movimento de implantação de
padrões relativamente ao cabelo
as mulheres começaram a questionar
outras coisas que você estava enterrando
os sonhos eram revoluções e essas
meninas começaram a questionar a deus
não só os técnicos do câmbio mas também
coletivamente ao corpo
porque é que eu tenho a ver uma peça de
roupa um determinado tamanho por ser
considerada bonita sexy maravilhosa
porque é que eu tenho que ter um
determinado corpo por ser considerada
bonita mani que a pessoa perfeita para
desfilar para apresentar roupas para
está à frente de tudo e todas
sim eu sou feminista mas tenham calma
não vim aqui te queimar sutiãs nem
atacar o mas o flamengo no qual eu
acredito é o fim mesmo com luta pela
igualdade de oportunidades da mulher
dentro do sistema que infelizmente ainda
prevalece machista e sexista
eu não quero que o sistema privilegia
como muitas pessoas pensam economistas
querem eu quero que o sistema me deu a
oportunidade de mostrar do que sou capaz
e não quero que o sistema não proteja
eu quero ter a oportunidade
g enquanto de ser eu não quero ser
categorizada como a frágil aqui não
consegue aqui tem que ter um apoio uma
mãozinha
não quero e eu enquanto mulher negra
encontro diversas barreiras e encontrou
diversas lutas para trabalhar cada vez
mais
imaginemos um campo de batalha onde de
um lado temos os homens e estes já está
em inúmeros concursos para conseguirem
atingir seus objetivos realizar
instruções consolidarem as suas vidas
profissionais e tem também a liberdade
de andar um lado para o outro à procura
de oportunidades e do outro lado temos
as mulheres cujas armas tão sutiãs nos
seus braços ter seus filhos e arrastam
consigo todas as tarefas domésticas
possíveis e imagináveis
dentro deste grupo de mulheres
temos um grupo neste subgrupo essas
mulheres têm tudo aquilo que já disse
que as outras têm inclusiva correndo nos
pés e no pescoço
a mulher negra a mulher negra
infelizmente é oprimida cada vez mais
pelo sistema não só pelo machismo pelos
accionistas como todas as outras
mulheres mas a mulher negra tem que
enfrentar a opção da sociedade
relativamente à como ela está como ela é
com ela se apresenta a mulher negra é
oprimido constantemente e pressionam
para que ela usa um cabelo liso
estamos mais perto daquilo que a mulher
branca que ela tenha um nariz fino que
ela tenha uma papel clara quanto mais
clara melhor lhes eram lentos e que ela
também tem um comportamento da mulher
branca porque os disseram que não gostam
de pretas canta lojas mas também a
pessoa negra falsa
sim eu sou uma negra fãs querem saber
por que quando as mulheres negras não se
enquadra naquilo que são padrões mais
perto da mulher branca não se constrói
um padrão estético da mulher africana
aquela mulher africana que nós todos
temos que conhecer aquela mulher que é
verdadeiramente africana e não tem rabo
muito grande não tem site e para eles eu
não sou ficando por ter falta dessas
coisas
para ele uma boa africana tem que ter um
corpo sim senhor tem que chegar e dizer
eu cheguei com o seu corpo da mulher
negra tem que ser gostosa
se não não é negra é qualquer coisa
mesmo de mulher negra defeito de fábrica
se calhar dentro do feminismo negro que
é o feminismo que acaba por não chamar a
atenção de que mulheres negras e
infelizmente estão em desvantagem o
sistema de que mulheres negros
infelizmente são oprimidas
eu aprendi que eu não preciso ter um
carro grande para sequestrar uma mulher
negra é não desistir saiu se não fosse
considerado mulher negra
eu não preciso chegar em toda a gente
está a olhar para o meu rabo por ser
considerada mulher negra dentro do filme
cisne negro eu aprendi que a minha
essência enquanto mulher não se termina
relativamente ao meu corpo que eu sou
mais não comprasse carro
as pessoas vêem na provisão na rua para
subir harém para dizer é gostosa eu sou
muito mais do que isto
eu não preciso esperar 15 mulher eu não
preciso disto para batalhar pelos meus
sonhos eu sou mulher negra porque eu
tenho a capacidade de chegar onde eu
quero chegar e lutar e ultrapassar todas
as barreiras
independentemente daquilo que vamos
dizer que independentemente daquilo que
é impresso em nível dizem tu não faz
parte daquilo que nós superamos isto não
é aquilo que eu acho que nós queremos
eu consigo ea minha essência as minhas
capacidades valem muito mais do que um
corpo por esse é só minha negra
o feminismo não serve para nos parar
o mesmo serve para uns unir para
justificar aquela idéia de que mulher só
são invejosas e não podem ser amigas
para desmistificar aquela ideia que nós
só queremos competir estamos lá
comentário mesmo dia no facebook mas na
verdade queremos matar aquela pessoa não
é um bicho está aqui para nos dizer que
nós podemos inserir mais que nós podemos
ser solidárias umas pelas outras
crónicas podemos fazer a diferença
apoiando umas às outras e o flamengo
também tem essa importância do
empoderamento e quando falamos do
empoderamento não são só com mulheres
nós precisamos nos homens também a
sociedade é constituída por homens
também e não existe um tempo de luta que
nós luxo se de que não tenha o apoio de
ambos os lados por isso nós precisamos
nos homens nós precisamos de todos em
poder há aquelas que infelizmente estão
em desvantagem no sistema
sim eu ia falar sobre deus
já vi no que isto deu uns inscrito
cabelo várias problemáticas ações uma
retirada uma resistência
eu espero ter um título com a vossa
consciência
obrigado